okay so this is onion friend a kind of a
funny story about this one we try
watching this two days ago funny of
getting violently ill is funny I got an
allergic reaction to something I have no
idea what cuz I didn't leave the house
or anything it just came out of nowhere
and it's like what you see in cartoons
like my body was red and there was a
rash spreading everywhere the little
bubbles I was like having a hard time
breathing
I never had this happen before where is
some and anaphylactic shock
so I just I go the doctor he's like
what's definite logic reaction just here
he gave me some steroids and take a few
bad trail it's like he has keep an eye
out if we could move the V logs to
another day and I said no and I beat him
horribly and when that still wasn't
working when his morale didn't improve
then I said maybe you should go see a
doctor so thank you for them they really
added a lot to my pain as a whole and
this time on earth I think a hole was
definitely involved yeah yeah it was and
be like if I gonna reuse it again but
yeah so this episode we actually saw two
days ago so we're kind of going off of
memory he watching it there was onion
and he was weird to the end uh yeah
how's it nothing else happened um no
this was a it hasn't happened to get by
the way I have no idea what that was um
I'm just gonna no it was definitely
allergic reaction and they say had to be
something that you like inhaled or
ingested that day but it's like I had
nothing dinner so it's just one of those
weird fucking things I have no idea what
it was hopefully won't happen again
that'll be a little dedicated dog
walkers this is the last video oh wow
what a what what a way to go out on the
onion episode I was allergic to any it's
Oh but okay so this is uh onion friend
this is episode where we finally see
onions mother uh we already saw his
father before but now we see his mother
um hilariously named Vidalia but that
thumb get it and her heads even shaped
like an onion um so at least that
confirms he's not like an alien or
anything
he still has no ears and no nose but
it's like you know I used to be human is
difficult he's a fucking onion that's it
yeah even though he has to I think human
parents I mean the fact that she looks
so much I can onion I thought she was a
gem honestly I thought like she's like
half gem or something I'll cut she's
kind of designed to like them too and
even has kind of that color like that
yellow color where they have like a red
and the purple and stuff so I don't know
I don't know the verdicts still out on
that or what but her name is Vidalia
she's an onion just an onion better you
know if gems can like have consciousness
and become people why can't and Weiss is
so difficult I mean they're just
building up for the inevitable gem onion
war it'll be like fucking Armageddon man
it's in the Bible read it really yeah
someone's back it's yeah okay like
somewhere I'm sure
though not revelations of vegetations ah
Alison okay visit vegetations and
visitations yeah I find that was amazing
that's really good this uh it's there so
shit I got chopped that joke that's way
too good
alright so they so um it turns out that
onions mother and amethyst had this
friendship a long time ago and they're
just catching up on old times and sir
sharing the feelings and stuff like that
so Steven tries to get along with them
you know he doesn't usually get along
because he's just fucking scary and he's
still fucking scary but I do something
you want father dambulla vent I'm like
oh my god there's gonna be a pit and
there's gonna be some girl in there and
it's gonna be put the lotion on the skin
there's get those again it's yeah but uh
no it was just a little toy collection
um it was like Legend of Zelda when he
opened the chest up I was like dude yeah
I want to uh but that's and then he kept
one of the mice in his mouth cuz that's
onion I honestly thought he sweetly I
honestly thought he fucking fed the
snake it could be another Mouse he could
maybe so fed that oh god you're right
yeah because it's not like there's one
Mouse and I see you don't know I'm
convinced I'm convinced that's what
happened that's that's a story I'm going
well maybe when when he would it look
like he did that I'm like man this shows
dark I mean
but do you realize what that meet you
okay either way it's disturbing because
let's say yeah yeah yeah well the whole
time it's still fucking scary fucking
nuts so um I like that guy
that's much over now over there that is
not as much as Ronaldo like Ronaldo I
actively hate this guy just I know that
like some weird about him somehow right
I mean I feel like I have the reaction
you're supposed to have to him like
you're supposed to be scared by him but
it's like he did one little right thing
so I guess it makes him okay but is he
like I don't think you're fully suppose
he's home buttering Stephen up for the
kill
got a little onion to serve man all over
come with me Stephen I have to the onion
cooks the man oh my god is said in
vegetations dogs and cats living
together mass hysteria
um but yeah so this guy's like the most
I like the connection between amethyst
and onion the other I thought that oh we
find out that one boy is also uh related
to onion I don't know if we ever knew
that it's like part of that trio that
hangs out and it turns out like the
whatever teenage boy I didn't actually
know if I cared I actually don't
whatever that was I'm like that came as
an inter um no I liked amethyst talking
with Vidalia because particularly I feel
like when you're a child that happens
all the time like two adults really need
together to get together just to vent
well yeah and I like normals overrated
yeah normally over liquor or chocolates
or something uh usually y-yeah say
that's usually the magic liquid
sometimes bourbon and cigarettes
depending on the problem but it like I
felt like I had like travel back and
like back in time but my parents have
done that and you're stuck there with
the weird kid and you're like huh like
it didn't happen all the time mostly cuz
I think I was the weird kid no I know
exactly you're like yeah that that's
sort of like I'm bored what do I do
then the weird kids suggest something
and you're like actually maybe I'd
rather be bored I you know I
no matter how weird you are I think
everyone has come across someone that's
even weird there's always I'm always
somebody weirder and cuz I'm with you I
always kind of felt like I was the weird
kid and stuff that unless you come
across last unless you're sitting there
right now going I can't think of anybody
weirder than yours
you're the less of the time oh sorry
get up embrace it embrace your weirdness
change the world with it hey why is
weird low you could be the fucking
highest on the totem pole yeah I mean
some oddball you're not that same weird
is always bad in onions case it's a
little off-putting
much like the smell of an onion but I
usually make it sometimes weird can be
really awesome when you get to know
weird and they're the right kind of
weird that we're that weird that you're
gonna wake up you know handcuffed to a
bed getting your you know fucking ankles
broken man that was a bad year anyway
yeah we're never taking that baby sink
job again that was very um but no I'm
totally with you in the I like that they
kept it from Steven's point of view
because I think like you said yes sir
took you back to oh yeah like I remember
like you know adults need to talk about
things and since it just sort of hiding
in the corner listening I kid kids would
do that they'd eat rap even if they
didn't really care that much what
they're talking about they're just oh
listen I was like a ninja yeah like our
aunt calls our aunt call me a spy and
basically like kick me out of the room
one time yeah I think all kids do that
but I don't know why there's something
about you don't want to interact like
might as well listen you know it's cuz
at the same time what I might be talking
about you know it's because you're both
yeah they might be talking about you and
there's always when you're a kid there's
always this kind of concept of when
adults get together secret shit happens
like like we're not supposed yeah it's
like oh yeah it's supposed to know our
kids you can leave the room and go play
it's like why what do you want to talk
about what's going on in here like you I
always just had this feeling like oh
they're gonna talk about something hmm
and it'll be interesting than half the
time I just ended up being bored but
everyone so I'd get that juicy tidbit
file it away for later and then you know
20 years later you'll get your bail
blackmail yeah
so um but no I that's the part I like
the most even though it's I like that
they kept it on Steven and onion because
I think that's what it had to be you
know just sort of be effective and you
know that what amethyst is talking about
is very important and it by seeing less
of them talking it actually sort of
makes the connection stronger because
they knew what to focus on and what to
have them say and by being away from it
you know they're still talking and it's
left open what they're saying you just
know it's important and that they are
bonding um so I like that I like that it
kept it to Steven and onion even if I'm
not the biggest fan of onion um but I
like this is such a fun job we could say
that I'm not the biggest fan of onion oh
I'm just saying I think onions killed a
few people I think door baby I know I
think there's in that secret room
there's another secret door like under
their bodies yeah under the floorboards
it did I it's just you know he's right
Edgar Allan Poe and he's like that's a
great idea under the book apart it is
just a mass grave there are more bodies
underneath those floorboards in the
entire series of Game of Thrones that's
all I'm saying
um I am NOT a disagreement with you um
but I don't it if I were to guess it
honestly invited guess what they're
gonna do what I really did happen to
rose then he's making friends with
Steven I'm just saying I wouldn't be
surprised that's the secret he's next on
the menu um no if I had to guess I think
they're building him up like he might be
bad he might be good but they're gonna
ultimately make him good oh he's not
gonna ban to God no I think that's why I
look a little bit belief Renaldo's bad
first around and I just like joking
about the fact he's probably you Syria
uh but that's my guess what they're
probably gonna do with them um but ya
know it's interesting how adult this
episode is even though there's very
little focus on adults on the adults in
it and that surprisingly made a little
bit more adult cuz it's being told from
the kids point of view which I thought
was very clever um like I said I like it
when a show can kind of bring back
something I kind of forgot from
childhood I think that is something all
kids go through because there's times
where adults need a dog where the
parents are
friends whatever and it's like you know
leave the room or they got up early to
hear a conversation every kids go on
through that so I think it's quickly
relatable and you always kind of knew it
was important so it was a very clever
way of sort of showing their friendship
and what they had through that point of
view um so yeah any other things to
clarify to talk about I I'm just not a
huge onion person maybe if it was a
carrot maybe Apple says they have to be
vegetable now in our mineral zucchini
it's making Italian